i almost wonder because you have to if i
correct if i'm wrong you have to
audition for hollow life right yeah
and i feel like when these positions in
this company where it's like you have to
audition for us
they can kind of use that power to even
then to make you
force you to take a shitty deal because
it's like right oh yeah it's 910
but yeah you know yeah what what's 10
when you're a nobody we can make you
it's it's it's also i mean it's also the
argument of
if you're signing with the agency you're
gonna get so much
publicity right right because because of
how massive hollow lighting totally
totally like with the english youtubers
that just debuted
every one of them has like got over 100k
subs just
like before yeah before they even
started streaming and now they're
putting in like
i remember i remember i was watching
mori stream yesterday and she was
putting in like
20 over like 30k concurrent viewers
streaming yeah and you just don't get
that starting out
by yourself as an independent that's
something you grow over years
it'd be interesting to see if that keeps
up as well yeah but yeah i i agree i
mean you could argue that
okay even if they are getting a bad cut
yeah well they're getting a free career
so they should be happy with that i'm
sure as well with how
powerful and like well-known hololive is
now in these agencies are
i'm sure that you know if they want to
go into like say
a lot of them are like aspiring voice
actors are like inspiring like you know
that kind of stuff i'm sure
getting into whole life is just a quick
shortcut to getting into
yeah i mean i'm i'm totally open and
happy if i'm wrong yeah
yeah i hope that it's an amazing [ __ ]
deal because i mean what is it like uh
how asaku had the most
uh what was it she was like the highest
earning super chat user
in the world like since debuting the
article i think she
she's like earned over like 800 or 900
thousand dollars
yeah which is [ __ ] insane and like i
hope most of that's going to hurt like
she deserves
yeah like she's the one doing all the
work for building this character
she deserves that money i just i i'm
hoping that they get that because the
thing about especially hololive
talent is that everyone is extremely
talented yeah like
they obviously can hold a stream really
well but a lot of them has
other other talents above that as well a
lot of them do like a lot of like
covers and stuff like that a lot of them
do like singing stuff and voice acting
so i mean that's [ __ ] awesome
is a [ __ ] pro tetris player or
something yeah that's right yeah yeah
maury can like she just released a song
the other day that's just like [ __ ]
she [ __ ] kind of like falling over
like it's his girlfriend
damn she's so talented bro i love her
i'm so proud of her i'm so proud of her
man
god opens up his phone and just smiles
at the lock screen oh
i'm so proud of you honey
like when sydney walks in [ __ ] change
the tab
it's sydney it's sydney yeah i mean
again like
right i'm just trying to like sell them
because i i feel like
i couldn't get yeah i couldn't get why
anyone would get into videos
until i got into videos and now it's
it's
it's really [ __ ] entertaining i
really want to talk about
how the reason i'm so obsessed with them
is because it's just a kind of
entertainment i couldn't find anywhere
else oh yeah i
agree it's definitely very unique yeah i
guess because like when i hear about it
and all of it
immediately my mind is like i want to
know how this works like that's
immediately what i want to know
i don't have any interest in anything
else i'm like this organization sounds
so unique like i want to know how all
this works how do they like how do you
decide how
yeah how do you decide the cuts how do
you decide what rules they have and
whatnot that's so interesting because i
feel like that's why
a lot of people got like mad at pokemane
when she
debuted her youtuber [ __ ] which i
think is fun
which i think is [ __ ] dumb that we're
[ __ ] gatekeeping people
putting an anime avatar of themselves
like come on come on guys
keeping's already [ __ ] done let alone
this kind of gay
but like i think what that stems from
right is the appeal of
vichy was like hollow live is completely
different from
just a normal stream of putting an anime
avatar above them
because like it's that it's that
character thing i talked about where
people don't view these people as people
or what they do but they also don't view
them as just a character as well
i think it's also mainstream uh
mainstreaming uh live streaming was was
so
mainstream like turned into a mainstream
especially with fortnight right like i
feel like
everyone [ __ ] live streams now you're
not special right cool go watch fortnite
right like whatever
because isn't it something like i think
you taught me this i heard from someone
at twitch i don't know how accurate this
is but apparently if you
average over 10 viewers on twitch per
stream you're in the top 10 percent of
tweets
jesus christ i hope that's real which is
if it's real
that's [ __ ] crazy because every
single console can live stream now
it's so [ __ ] amazing it's so easy to
lie it used to be like you'd have a
[ __ ] beefy boy
yeah running and streaming right so i
feel like he was almost
at least i don't know correct me if i'm
wrong right that's what it felt like it
felt like
this one thing that felt kind of unique
in streaming was then just mainstreaming
yeah yeah the other people coming in i
mean it's dirty irl streamers
they're coming in those dirty normies
coming into my
circle taking over my anime girls
nah not i wish i could filter myself
live like in my photos but i can't so
how about i just
make myself beautiful i'll just remake
myself completely
yeah yeah i get it man i'm lazy as [ __ ]
i look ugly as [ __ ]
off my streams bro i wanna i wanna i
mean hey man i'm already prepared to
you know enjoy a couple of youtuber
streams when i get home tonight